- Did either one of you ever do ballet?
- No.
- I have taken ballet, yeah.
- You did?
- I did, yeah.
I mean, yeah, it was
more because I was doing
like musical theater and stuff growing up.
So we had to take a ballet class,
but I actually quite enjoyed it.
I mean, I really liked it a lot.
- It's hard.
- Matter of fact,
we had to do it all.
We had to do tap, jazz all that stuff.
And ballet was by far my
favorite, I'm not sure why.
- My husband did ballet, and he loved it.
- That's so good.
Man, if you love it, you're good at it...
That was my, that was my weakest one, man.
- I didn't love the dance belt.
Didn't love the dance belt.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. (laughs)
- For the men out there
that are not familiar
with what a dance belt does, it goes...
It's a thong.
- It's a thong.
- It's a jock-strap thong hybrid.
- You know what, though?
Just lean in and own it,
that's what I say. (laughs)